kerry le bonjour vous êtes au palais
bourbon le nouveau gouvernement doit
entrer en scène dans peu de temps
at on une idée des questions qui seront
à l'ordre du jour alors il vient
d'entrer en scène comme à chaque début
de séance avec cette arrivée solennel du
président de l'assemblée un richard
ferrand qui est arrivé il ya quelques
minutes avec un bruit de tambour et puis
en ce qui concerne les questions qui
vont être abordés aujourd'hui vous savez
que c'est la première séance de
questions au gouvernement qui était
tellement attendu depuis la nomination
de jean castex à la place d'edouard
philippe qui est retourné dans son fief
du havre et on sait aussi que ces
nominations rond un fait se poser
beaucoup de questions au gouvernement
notamment en ce qui concerne gérald
darmanin par exemple qui a été nommé
ministre de l'intérieur gérald harlin
qui est actuellement visé pour eux par
une enquête pour viol et harcèlement
sexuel bien qu'il reste présumé innocent
on a aussi pu voir certain étonnement
suite à la nomination d'eric
dupond-moretti à la justice eric dupond
moretti qui a récemment fait savoir
qu'il souhaitait garder tout ce qui
fonctionnait a actuellement et virer
tout simplement tout ce qui ne
fonctionnait pas donc voilà autant de
questions qu'on pourra entendre
aujourd'hui on parlera aussi de
l'égalité hommes femmes comme l'a fait
savoir une députée et les robes en début
de séance en tout cas cette séance va
commencer désormais on en saura plus
tout au long de cet après midi avant que
le gouvernement ne
ne se rende au sénat merci beaucoup
kirill kotick off pour toutes ces
précisions vous étiez donc en direct du
palais bourbon